hola de nuevo en este vídeo vamos a
seguir resolviendo problemas acerca de
integrales definidas y espero que
podamos resolver este problema que vamos
a ver a continuación aunque también me
gustaría que ustedes entendieran bien
por qué se resuelven las filas
integrales definidas y eso no viene en
todos los libros de texto así que espero
que te quede la idea de por qué se
resuelven así las integrales pero bueno
es hora de empezar a jugar un poco y voy
a ponerle el nombre a ese ese es una
función del tiempo entonces ese que
depende del tiempo va a ser igual y esta
vez en lugar de tomarme una parábola voy
a tomarme una función cubica va a ser la
función a dos veces te kubica dese
cuenta que esta vez no solamente la
aceleración aumenta también aumenta la
tasa de cambio de la aceleración eso
creo que se llama tirón no estemos
seguro pero busquen de la wikipedia
bueno entonces tenemos la función 2 t
kubica ya esto hay que sumarle 5
unidades porque empezamos 5 unidades
después del origen o dicho de otra
manera cuando nosotros empezamos a
contar en el tiempo ya
hemos recorrido 5 pies es decir mi
distancia iba a empezar 5 pies después
del origen bueno y ahora yo quiero saber
cuál va a ser esta distancia del tiempo
dos segundos al tiempo cinco segundos
este va a ser mi problema en esta
ocasión yo lo que quiero encontrar es
cuál es la distancia que yo voy a
recorrer dada mi función de distancia
del tiempo dos segundos al tiempo cinco
segundos pues vamos a ver supongamos que
aquí estoy en el dos segundos aquí
tienes cinco segundos y si yo
sustituyera mis cinco segundos en mi
función original
no voy a poner con otra cosa un poco más
llamativo este color no suena muy muy
opaco voy a poner un color más alegre
bien ha sido sustituyó el 5 en función
del tiempo y obtendría 5 al cubo que 125
por 2 250 más 5 255 pies muy bien y
ahora qué va a pasar si yo sustituyó el
2 en mi función de distancia pues 2 al
cubo es 8 por 2 16 más 5 es 21 entonces
21 10
bien ya tengo lo que me tendría que
salir ahora bien si yo quisiera saber
cuál es la distancia que yo recuerdo del
tiempo cinco segundos al tiempo dos
segundos pues esto es lo mismo que ese
de cinco ya esto le quitamos ese dedo o
dicho de otra manera es la función
evaluada en 5 - la función evaluada en 2
es una diferencia pero la función
evaluada 5 era 255 y la función evaluada
en 2 era 21 por lo tanto si los restamos
no van a quedar 234 pies yo ya sea al
menos mi resultado mi resultado de la
distancia que recorro del tiempo igual a
2 segundos al tiempo igual a 5 segundos
dada mi función de distancia es igual a
234 pies ahora lo que voy a hacer es lo
mismo que del vídeo pasado
voy a intentar primero sacar la derivada
de ese dt es decir la velocidad del que
depende del tiempo desde t es la primera
derivada de ese de t con respecto al
tiempo y es una derivada muy sencilla es
6 t cuadrada más pues más nada porque
recuerden que la derivada una constante
es cero y esto quiere decir que la
velocidad es independiente del lugar en
donde empecemos la vela
sería igual si empezamos 5 pies después
del origen o si empezamos 8 pies después
del origen o si empezamos 1000 pies
después del origen la velocidad es
independiente del punto en donde
empecemos nuestro movimiento y es por
eso que la derivada ese 5 desaparece
pero bueno vamos a graficar esto como
nos va a quedar la gráfica de 6 t
cuadrada
pues es una parábola que empieza en el
origen entonces yo tengo 9 me dice que
es el tiempo en otro de mis ejes a la
velocidad y esta va a ser la gráfica de
btt o sea 6 de cuadrada muy bien este es
el tiempo estas veces velocidad y bueno
qué pasa si yo os pregunto lo mismo que
en el vídeo pasado es decir si yo
solamente tengo la gráfica de la
velocidad o la función vedete que
depende del tiempo que me grafica la
velocidad cómo puedo saber la distancia
que he recorrido del tiempo igual a dos
segundos hasta el tiempo igual a cinco
segundos y por la red la respuesta sería
muy parecida a la vez pasada en la vez
pasada yo hice varios varios rectángulos
con una anchura de
dt y que era un tiempo muy pequeño casi
instantáneo y yo después de una altura
de esa velocidad es instantánea que
tenían por ser un tiempo muy pequeño
oops
bien y entonces yo sólo hice solamente
un rectángulo y yo hice muchos
rectángulos varios rectángulos y tomaba
la suma de todos estos rectángulos miren
qué bueno está quedando todos estos
rectángulos y yo tomaba la suma de todos
estos rectángulos y con esta suma de
todos los rectángulos se obtenía una
buena aproximación acerca de la
distancia que yo quería obtener de hecho
recuerdan que cada uno de los
rectángulos que yo tengo el área de cada
uno de los rectángulos que yo obtengo es
la distancia en un tiempo muy pequeño en
un tiempo casi instantáneo y después yo
despejaba a mi distancia de la fórmula
de velocidad y obtenía qué distancia es
igual a velocidad por tiempo y con todo
esto yo me daba cuenta que el área de
uno de los rectángulos delgados era la
distancia en un tiempo muy corto y bueno
con toda la suma de todos estos
rectángulos yo obtuve la noción
de integrado porque yo lo que hacía era
que te lo tendía a cero para hacer una
infinidad de rectángulos y así obtener
la integral entonces eso es lo que vamos
a hacer ahorita ya tengo todos mis
rectángulos aquí están muchos
rectángulos y entonces voy a hacer la
mejor aproximación con la suma infinita
es decir la integral definida del tiempo
igualados al tiempo igual a 3 y ahora sí
vamos a escribirlo yo tengo la integral
de baa1 de hecho el al revés
era de a ave porque b es el más grande
recuerden que arriba siempre va el más
grande de hecho lo voy a poner de
amarillo la integral de ave de mi
función velocidad que era 6 de cuadrada
6 t cuadrada diferencial de t y éste era
a y éste era b y entonces ahora sí a
vale 2 b vale 3 y solamente me resta
resolver esta integral que esta integral
la resolvemos primero la integral
indefinida y después evaluamos en
villena
pero la integral de 6 de cuadrados la
integran muy fácil la integral de t
cuadrada este cúbica entre 3 y múltiple
por 62 de kubica entonces lo voy a notar
aquí tengo 2 te ubica evaluado de de aa
es más de hecho voy a poner de una vez
los números evaluado de 5 era de 5 a 2 y
solamente hay que sustituir el 5 aquí
que me daría 5 al cubo que 125 por 250
ya esto le tendría que quitar lo mismo
valor de 2 ya lo quiero confundirlos más
así que no voy a seguir evaluando y
solamente les voy a decir la más
importante de todo este ejercicio lo más
importante fue que uno la anti derivada
es lo mismo que el área abajo en la
curva eso es muy importante y lo segundo
es que en casi todos los libros ustedes
van a ver esta anotación la integral de
a a b de fx de x es igual a efe
mayúscula evaluado en b
- efe evaluado en a y este es el teorema
fundamental del cálculo esto es muy
importante y es una notación que usa
mucho en libros y que quiere decir que
la integral de ave de fx de x es la anti
derivada o la primitiva evaluada en b
menos restándole la primitiva adelante
derivada evaluada en la es decir
evaluamos en b la anti derivada
evaluamos en la y calculamos su
diferencia que es lo que hemos estado
haciendo nosotros hasta ahorita y de
hecho espero que con todo esto que hemos
creado desde la intuición de por qué es
esta fórmula que aparece en todos los
libros pero bueno puede intentar
escribirlo de una manera mucho más
limpia en un siguiente pizarrón para que
quede todo más en orden y más claro bien
ok es aquí bien entonces que dije hasta
ahorita que si f mayúscula de x es igual
a la integral no no no no es pues me
dejaba borrar esa sí es cierto esto pero
le voy a poner de una manera mucho más
intuitiva si la derivada con respecto a
x df mayúscula de x es igual a fx a efe
minúscula de x entonces este es el
teorema fundamental del cálculo y debe
ser muy importante porque le ponen
fundamental entonces supongo que debe
ser indispensable para entender todo el
cálculo y es crítica si lo que está
diciendo está diciendo una cosa muy
importante que si la derivada con
respecto a x de una función f mayúscula
de x es igual a efe de x entonces la
integral de a a b de fx df minúscula de
x de x es igual a s mayúscula evaluada
en b ya esto le vamos a restar es
mayúscula evaluada en a es decir que la
derivada y la integral tienen mucho que
ver y bueno espero que yo en esto
cuántos vídeos han 23 proclaman 3 en
estos 3 vídeos yo les haya creado la
intuición de por qué es esta fórmula era
mi intención en estos tres vídeos así
que creo que vale mucho la pena el
dedicarle los siguientes vídeos a seguir
analizando esta fórmula que realmente es
muy sencilla y aplicar solamente esta
fórmula así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo